like as somebody who thinks click bait
journalism is broken
journalists annoy the hell out of me hey
journalism is working perfectly
journalism is broken journalism things
work great
so i understand from putin's perspective
that journalism journalists can be seen
as the enemy of the state because
people think journalists write these
deep
beautiful philosophical pieces about
criticizing the structure of government
and the
proper policy where you know the steps
that we need to take
to make a greater nation no they they're
unfairly take stuff out of context
they uh they're critical in ways that's
like
shallow and not interesting they they
call you a racist
or sexist or they make up stuff all the
time
so i can put myself in the mindset of a
person that thinks that
it is okay to remove that kind of
shallow
fake news voice from the system the
problem is of course
that is a slippery slope to then
you remove all the annoying people from
the system and then you
change what annoying means which
annoying starts becoming a thing that
like anyone who opposes
the the system i mean i get i get the um
the slippery it's obvious it becomes a
slippery slope but i can also put myself
in the mindset of the people that see
it's okay to remove the liars from the
system
as long as it's good for russia and okay
so here in lies and this again the
traditional american perspective because
we've had yellow so-called yellow
journalism since the founding of the
republic that's nothing new
um but but the problem then comes into
play
when you remove journalists even you
know
it's a broad brush thing because but you
remove both the the crappy ones who are
lying
and the ones who are telling the truth
too you're left with simply
the the approved government journalists
right the ones who are toeing
the government's line in which case the
truth
as you see it is a different kind of
fake news right it's the fake news from
the government
instead of the click bait news and oh
yeah maybe
truth mixed into all that too in some of
the outlets
the problem i always have with our
system here in the united states right
now is
trying to tease the truth out from all
the falsehoods
and look i've got 30 years in journalism
my job used to be to go through before
the internet
all the newspapers and and find the i
used to know all the journalists by name
and i could pick out you know who they
were
and and and i have a hard time picking
out the truth from the falsehood so i
think constantly
how are people who don't have all this
background who have lives or who are
trained in other specialties
how do they do it but if the government
is the only approved
outlet for truth a traditional american
and a lot of other traditional societies
based on these ideas of the
enlightenment that i talked about
earlier
would see that as a disaster waiting to
happen or a tyranny in progress does
that make sense
it totally makes sense and i would agree
with you i still agree with you
but it is clear that something about the
freedom
of the press and freedom of speech
in today like literally the last few
years with the internet
is changing and the argument you know
you you could say that the american
system of freedom of speech
is is broken because the
here's here's the belief i grew up on
and i still hold
but i'm starting to be sort of trying to
see multiple
views on it my belief was that freedom
of speech
results in a stable trajectory towards
truth always
so like truth will emerge that was my
sort of faith and belief
that that yeah there's going to be lies
all over the place but there will be
like a stable
thing that is true that's carried
forward
to the public now it feels like
it's possible to go towards a world
where
nothing is true or truth is
is something that groups of people
convince themselves of and there's
multiple groups of people
and the idea of some universal truth as
i suppose is the better
thing is uh is something that we can no
longer
exist under like some people believe
that the green bay packers is the best
uh football team and some people can
think the patriots
and they deeply believe it
to where they call the other groups
liars now that's fun for sports that's
fun for
favorite flavors of ice cream but they
might believe that about science
about uh the various aspects of
politics various aspects of sort of uh
different policies within the
functioning of our government
and like that's not just like some weird
thing we complain about but that'll be
the nature of things like truth is
something we could no longer
have well let's and let me
de-romanticize the american
history of this too because the american
press
was often just as biased just as i mean
i always looked to the 1970s as the high
watermark of the american
journalistic in the post-watergate era
where it was actively going after
um the abuses of the government and all
these things but there was a famous
speech
very quiet though very quiet given by
catherine graham who was a
washington post editor i believe and uh
i actually somebody sent it to me we had
to get it off of a journalism
uh like a jstor kind of thing and she
at a at a luncheon um assured that the
to the government people at the luncheon
don't worry this is not going to be
something that we make a trend
we're not because the position
of the government is still something
that was
carried you know the the newspapers were
the water and the newspapers were the
big thing up until
certainly the late 60s early 70s the
newspapers were still the water carrier
of the government right
and they were the water carriers of the
owners of the newspaper
so let's not pretend there was some
angelic wonderful time and i'm saying to
me
because i was the one who brought it up
um let's not pretend there was any
super age of truthful journalism and all
that and i mean you go to the
revolutionary period in american history
and it looks every bit as bad as today
right um that's a hopeful message
actually so things may not be as bad as
they look well let's look at it more
like a stock market and that you have
fluctuations in the truthfulness or or
believability of the press
and there are periods where it was
higher than other periods the funny
thing about the so-called click bait era
and i do think it's terrible
but i mean it resembles earlier eras to
me
so i always compare it to when i was a
kid growing up when i thought journalism
was as good as it's ever gotten it was
never perfect
but it's also something that you see
very rarely
in in other governments around the world
and there's a reason that journalists
are often killed
regularly in a lot of countries and it's
because they report on
things that the authorities do not want
reported on and i've always thought that
that was what journalism should do
but it's got to be truthful otherwise
it's just a different kind of propaganda
right
you